citizens of the reject Nation we are
about to watch the animated version of
one of my favorite Batman comics Batman
hush so please do hit that notification
Bell hit that subscribe button hit that
comment bar leave a little comment
what's uh one of your favorite Batman
comics do you like hush because I like
hush quite a bit and of course leave a
like as well while you're pressing all
those buttons but Greg did tell me he
prefaced this different in the comic
very curious how this differs what's
going on how are you the comic I checked
it out of the library a bunch of times I
probably read a couple pages and never
finished it so this is going to be great
I am very intrigued by how those pages
relate whether or not you remember those
pages at all judgmental about those
specifications six pages I enjoyed of
Jim Leon years ago very different we're
about to find out so please do check
that out as well as checking out a brand
new Batman shirt the bad verse we're
tying things together in averse of bats
we got all the Batmans in honor of both
Batman hush and the Flash because
they're some Batman in there as well and
as ever if you would like to watch this
in its entirety if you want to see us
hush
then become a patron that's the only
place you're gonna see us quiet frankly
you want those moments of Silence those
moments of reverence be a patron front
to back start to finish full Journey but
without further Ado it's time
to hush
[Music]
we're not driving what's happening whoa
I'm confused don't don't get too
creative damn I don't know if I trust it
it is acceptable to take one night off
speak to someone about sports yeah
Selena Kyle is here perhaps Miss Kyle is
definitely Alfred come on for at least a
year 16 months come on it's cap
always at the light let's go they're on
a group call found out the shipment was
tonight so thought I'd torch it
yes I weighs it on fire how you been
Selena you could say I'm at a Crossroads
I used to love my work at the gallery
this is Thomas Elliott good friend and
world renowned brain surgeon and I
wouldn't say world renowned maybe the US
and parts of Canada that's the world all
right Bane has abducted a child this
needs my attention but it was good
seeing you I'd like to catch up yeah you
would
mysterious unknown number
that glimmer in her eyes eight-year-old
Edward Dupree has been kidnapped by the
criminal known as Bane he has demanded
an undisclosed Ransom ah news 52 miles
yeah it's a whole reboot of the news
brand new universe of news we have your
money don't hurt the boy you me and
Dupree's money
just love the idea that Bane watches the
news yes I love this commercial
the lying Legacy Media I must take to
True social the anger changed his hair
her Venom social
everything will be
fun
[Laughter]
my Venom is stronger I am stronger
stupid or bad
[Music]
ah in the face
must be extremely painful for him for
him to be a side effect of the new Venom
which means his mind is under the same
strength
oh you're a junkie Venom I mean Bane
you're a Venom junkie Bane it's a lot of
words go together
get it
good shot
get him Harry did good
oh
Ivy the League of Assassins has no
business here the league has been in
flux and in the chaos the life-giving
power of a Lazarus Pit was exploited by
an unknown Intruder yes if you know
anything of this matter no but I'll look
into it next time call First
wait where's the ransom
ah
she take it come on world's greatest
detective
oh
I was about to say I thought it was
Catwoman following him personally
disappointed yeah it's a good mislead
with uh Shiva yeah
Catwoman
turkey long enough
they have the professional respect that
when they're in you know their suits
yeah who knows who might be listening on
rooftops
Catwoman knows the train schedules
and now
oh oh wow
they just decapitated one of Disneyland
oh hush Batman they're doing a cold rap
grabbing some of the imagery and like
the impact from the Jim Lee art yeah and
like making it work but I I do see a
couple little tweaks already it's
interesting
um
theme music too yeah it was really
unnerving violin told you it was him
fell out of the sky like a dead pigeon
what the hell there's only one way to
deal with this freak
and then ate that one there's a three
strikes law in this state boys
foreign
[Music]
you know some guys pay for that I was
about to say you better hope he's not
into that
hey yeah all right
dang
dang get away from him you're working
with Bane and you're going down come
quietly and you won't get hurt Ah that's
adorable
but is it a cat fight or a bat fight
take care of your boss
he's not my boss
we are colleagues what happened they
couldn't keep up don't worry yourself
with anyone or anything except pleasing
me
yes mistress is that Lake Bell oh maybe
I think it is I wonder if she was this
before early
oh that's the guy glimmer you can go now
ah okay damn it I was just about to ship
them but Harley hey that's true that's
true and bats they're so cute and bats
what the
[Music]
50 50. maybe I'll finish our deal
another way oh
if my vitals don't remain well vital
I have a job that will pay 10 times what
you made today think of all the
fertilizer you could buy
his head injury is beyond me I'm afraid
he needs a hospital Batman can go to the
hospital but Reckless Playboy Bruce
Wayne can absolutely Dick Grayson will
take him to the emergency room 45 miles
an hour should be adequate remember to
tuck and roll pretty screwed up you guys
have a plan for this I got an
encyclopedia yeah this situation this
had trauma surgery couldn't have gone
better
hey but you don't have to stay out of
the fast lane for a while I owe you so
much it's the least I can do for all the
time to left you hanging oh wait
I haven't been a very good friend you
kidding me look at all the publicity you
gave me hey I searched for searching
friend I need to go to Black gate prison
my dad suggest this one
oh a headpiece has a bit more padding
it's the bat concussion suit but cool
for the world's greatest vegetable sir
hahaha
I love a Batman vegetable costume I love
the use of bottles I always forget
that's what Butler's you know piece of
there but bottle
I need to speak with Bane I believe he's
working with Poison Ivy and Catwoman I
need to know why five minutes is all no
what's going on didn't you sedate him
yes ma'am enough to drink a herd of
elephants
oh they wanted him to get arrested Ivy
was controlling me she made me steal
your money
first
verse
that woman down
and a Little Help from Spider-Man
that is a strong drone yeah
hahaha
pin cushioned him his trunks to the face
you're going after Ivy and I want in I
have a code Revenge isn't part of it how
about the address of our pheromone
controlled minions give me the
information and I'll take care of Ivy
nope
fine we work together on this what's the
address oh I'm not done with my demands
yes
we've done this dance for so long why
don't you just the least bit curious
[Music]
oh the back kiss back curiosity killed
the bat
oh yeah good shot right through the
shattered glass capes of billowing Avis
and Metropolis
oh get the jet ready very
pack the jewelry
I want to look pretty while I do this I
need my rings on how come you're still
hanging around don't you have an
interview he's coming here quite the get
whoo that would be me
turtleneck yeah the turtleneck something
tells me a man like you is here for more
than an interview I do like to multitask
don't tell me you and the boy scout have
switched cities
[Music]
Lex Corp makes a fortified ethylene
compound engineered to allow exotic
plants to withstand changes in locale
I need the delivery list of that
compound for the last week and you
couldn't visit the person who does the
deliveries and is probably awake as we
speak
information was deleted on her computer
I assume yours has a few more safeguards
one or two
and my own screensaver my name on it
thrifted building I saved all your asses
against Cyborg Superman and I'll remind
you I'm a Justice League member now
yes you are
I just realized this was that Cannon
yeah because the rain Wilson boys I was
like I think I love his Lex Luthor oh
it's so fun I've come back to you no one
can resist you that's so true kitty but
no one fakes it with me
okay crazy plant
all right
cpb
nose filters
[Music]
I get close why don't you
is Batman your new boy toy
it's always been
I have one too oh yeah
kill them oh don't do his Subs you just
came back fight this according to this
continuity
damn
[Music]
that Batman always so prepared I mean
make fun of the bat utility belt all you
want but he's got everything you will
ever need Gizmo's at the ready back
shirt repellent they're going in the
water
I don't get my money if they're still
alive I won't
are you trying to resist
oh seems my kryptonite kisses need a
touch-up
damn
find them kill them yes
God that green streak that was cool yeah
he's still looking at her like they'll
buy us some time but this is Superman
and if he wanted we'd be dead already
oh deep down he's a good person and deep
down I'm not oh oh Bruce Kryptonite
brass knuckles I've opened the gas mate
one spark from your heat vision you blow
up the entire block and you know what
building we're under
[Music]
made you look moment of distraction
the gas main I lied
whoa
[Music]
oh that's better of a good contingency
plan
get control you can save her it's your
choice not Ivy's wow that blackmail damn
it
okay looks like we do it the hard way
oh no
[Music]
imagery
he made me do it double date there's a
great comic that's Batman double dating
with super van Lois and Catwoman it's so
good two issues and it's some of the
best I'm buying it's second we're done
actually two of my favorite issues at DC
ever hit
synthetic Kryptonite you know who made
it working on it
they keep not even bothering
to like cut her off with something yeah
they're just almost sweaters it's the
Walmart of Poison Ivy's just
[Music]
consider it oh not the hair
name now hush it's true he calls himself
hush
I think your business here is done
I'm going to slowly float this way get
out of my city as I hover away
weren't supposed to throw Lois off the
roof
ugh Superman was going to he's still
covered for her so I improvised that's
what Partners do right oh
the little cat head bow
oh yes yes
Batman find happiness pennyworth tells
me you're romantically involved with a
Criminal now
it's only a date there are no ex
criminals father only ones who aren't
breaking the law at the moment
how long did you take to line this Frame
Up
it's pretty poised for any mission of
ours is a lonely endeavor
if this trala provides some carnal
release so be it oh however I must
insist that you use protection and
another thing to cover your drink
yes cover your drink Batman don't get
roofied man
oh my God that's my favorite birds of
the Beast talk I don't know
[Music]
oh he's not coming how are you and what
do you know about my pudding I know he
needs your help oh what
you know I had a bet with Eartha here
that you wouldn't show up Earth
the KitKat lemon juice I've just been
feeling the need to change some things
I've done some changing myself since we
first met thought maybe that's why you
dropped me I like that about you I hope
you're not entirely tamed
but I'd like to balance things more sure
good for you too get after it break out
that Chris Christian Gray contract oh
yes
yes they do it's a safe words Martha
what'd you say the name
I mean hers is Clark and that's not sure
how much he'd love to watch an Italian
Cloud but I do like it's mirroring The
Dark Knight mass that mirrors the
original uh Batman 66 mask sure that's
clever it's a reference and a reference
the turducken of clownery along with the
Opera robbing you for a thousand box of
tickets
I'm also here for my puddin who's been
clown napped oh there you are
Bruce Wayne nice tax hope it's not a
rental
oh you never get your deposit back get
the ladies to safety okay but I'm coming
back what are you gonna do I'll be a
hero Tom rabbit
[Applause]
what is the caliber on that thing strong
very strong I thought it was a flare gun
but it's just a giant bullet like a
Mario Super Mario balencias
laughs
dang
[Music]
[Applause]
no what is it the theater folks say
oh she had a little blood stash back
there you've been hurt
not that bad
bad smirk
[Laughter]
oh no
oh geez is that Thomas on the ground
yeah
Joker you know what the joke is I'm
totally innocent well that doesn't even
sound right does it
does not I was in a basement until five
minutes ago I'm also looking for Harley
have you seen
Revenge bats
it's not fun if it's not me
I want you to break your code but for
something I actually did yeah Gotham
needs Batman
oh
Man Hands of Fury and rage
tangents veg with Justice
well back to the Grind
who's Robin these days
ouch
well it's not Jason Todd store your
Treasures in Heaven where moths and rust
cannot destroy and thieves do not break
in and steal it's a real scripture
where'd a good moths then go there's no
mods in heaven
judgment
when your eye is healthy
your whole body is filled with light but
when your eye is unhealthy
Proud Family
and if the light you think you have is
actually Darkness how deep that darkness
is sermon especially for you bat sermon
it was all planned so Joker would wake
up in time to free himself arriving just
as Tom was killed the events of the past
months reach as high as Superman and as
low as the Joker
the full spectrum but why kill Thomas
Elliot he's got no connection to Batman
did have one with Bruce Wayne hush knows
Bruce Wayne is Batman oh boy let's not
wait another 10 years before seeing each
other okay there's just some business I
need to take care of first if I were you
I wouldn't wait too long I
hey I was seeing someone on and off
before you called ah
a mystery man what may the best mystery
man win
be careful what you wish for
stay safe Bruce
I wish for all of it
[Laughter]
this truck's defying physics yes Riddler
that's sea Lister
it's like they're all crawling out from
under the carpets now Riddler is is like
B to eight here no he's leveled up since
hush he's iconic I want you to know him
for this thing you and Selena
Bruce Lena
Bruce Lee that
mutton shop Riddler oh I just walked in
front of that one guy firing
trust that guy's not gonna clip him
[Applause]
oh
yeah a battering ram
bat pun
no where is he I know not whom you speak
of hush put you up to this can you
rephrase that in the form of a riddle
this has got to be exhausting dealing
with you can't even imagine
you know shake things up shake shake
shake
oh
make it over there just just watching
who are you
I'm the man that will destroy your life
before taking it
oh
[Applause]
soon Batman
very soon
that mean you always do that mirror
trick you know better yeah you're the
mirror guy he won the the one Hall too
frankly those are changing rooms you
just got mad at Express
[Laughter]
grab some of those discounts on the way
out that's true I want you to leave town
I don't
have but you don't get to tell me what
to do hush told me he's going to hurt
the ones closest to me the ones I care
for most oh I suffered a loss it's been
suggested that I'm handling it better
because I have you in my life
in your life isn't that a bit much
maybe it's time to find out
are you sure I am then let me oh Bruce
Bruce Wayne is Batman
I can think of a few things
not getting out of town any faster oh no
no no no
go up in the bat in the cat
I hate waiting
but that scrapes
I had to upgrade my kevlar Body Armor
after that uh sorry nah you make me
better
that was why you broke it
that's when you found out I was Maniac
[Applause]
stopping and if you can't control your
actions you're not quite sane and I was
wrong
wrong oh
thank you
that's what Nightwing thousand is free
time
200 300 500 a thousand the Liberty to
prepare tea with the Salted biscuits so
everyone knows who I am
there's Damian Robin his
son
[Laughter]
I love his displeased grunts if they can
land Brave in the Bold to be this tone
yeah fun but still dark and like family
and Bruce's both things yeah dude
hey penguin
Harvey
[Music]
and these guys and henchmen hold on the
henchmen
no
oh poor Alfred
The Cry of freeze
oh my bad sauna what is that yeah what
what is that tube I don't know
look at this
I'll even pay
foreign
Bruce I'm asking you to spend some time
away from this with me
two minutes ago a silent alarm was
tripped at a medical practice
the office belongs to that doctor hush
killed at the Opera Thomas Elliott oh
maybe this is something the Batman needs
to do alone this shouldn't take long
extreme vacations they can do the
mission impossible to climb that's the
only way Bruce getting out of town it's
extreme vacation yeah
glioblastoma multiform brain tumor
nearly inoperable you up for a trip to
Arkham oh joy oh joy
yeah he's not gone anywhere
suspect believed to be inside the ground
maybe the two coolest Side characters
teaming up yes
I forgot how much really like shifted
the tone of Batman books like the reveal
of Bruce Wayne the Catwoman like all
that I've been here before
so have you
oh damn it just let him rest in peace
but why would someone Nightwing
whoa my man have a face full of fear
oh here we go
no
faded Master Nicholas
I'd want you to play
he looks cool yeah the moonlight's red
have you smelled yourself lately yeah
you smell like dank burlap crane
no he'll kill
cannot fail
sure you can ass
dead ass
oh
ah take your zydrate oh whoa
sure remote
[Music]
it's cool
I like that
damn it
I wouldn't want to make it too easy
[Music]
oh the claw it moves when I saw the name
Arthur Wynn and Thomas Elliott's files I
knew he was more than a bit player okay
I'll bite who's Arthur
it was the name you used when visiting
Dr Thomas Elliot for your brain tumor
oh I refuse to let that be the end of Me
no no I found another way
or a Lazarus Pit oh yeah in that moment
I saw it who is the Batman
oh
[Music]
I needed a new persona my true identity
had to be kept Hush Hush
I convinced cajoled and compelled the
others to play their part and do my
bidding damn riddled me this
Commissioner Gordon
where'd my scar go is Batman oh Jesus
[Music]
oh Clayface
finally I'm free
cool
dinner and a show hey I love that
Joker's just in gen pop like yep what's
the worst that could happen is hammer on
everybody
you're seeing another villain already
thought we had something special
how many others were there no don't tell
me I love jealous lover Joker so much
it's not doing much Gordon oh
now you're just waiting on my parade bat
hose
oh
anyone got a mint
you see I went to the graveyard to catch
a bat but was off by a letter
toodles
Batman will come alone he'll compile a
list of every Factory and Warehouse
within the 10 mile radius of which there
are 62. he will not watch the road
check the names of the 14 places to find
that only one is an anagram for Arthur
Nguyen
riddle me this
the less of me you have the more I am
worth
it's time it's time
friend
ew I'm going to kill you you're not
going anywhere except down
yeah going down
[Music]
evil dies tonight
what's a bat to do
[Music]
the briefest of reprieves I assure you
yikes
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
Can you feel it Bruce Can you feel it
all slipping away
can you feel your extreme vacation
evaporating
yeah always did what do you think of me
now that you're the same insecure
c-lister you were before you went into
the Lazarus Pit
you tell riddles a fifth grader could
solve and you call yourself The Riddler
geez best of Ivy Joker and Bane once
they find out hush was the Riddler
they'll hunt you down like a dog they're
all going to laugh at you the effects of
the pit don't last forever I'm betting
even now you can feel it all that
strength ingenious slipping away just
when you need it most
riddle me this who's His Own Worst Enemy
hahaha
oh
I have you now
nick of time
oh
it's got to be so freaking hot in here
they're all wearing leather yes they're
just gonna pull out that's a big jacket
this is like all the sweat
that was gushy yeah
remember
now let's beat the crap out of this
yes
that's the cat in the ass hole
[Music]
damn yep
go you're Batman you can't let me die
ugh screw this
[Music]
they really
the religious Berks of Riddler there
damn I was I was oh not expecting that
you have to repeat that he killed your
friend
tried to murder Nightwing how he almost
killed me and you're sorry he's dead if
someone can be saved
try
seems like he only got worse you and
your God code and you'll die because of
it you know this right will that make it
all better oh without a code
I can't believe I let myself get caught
up in this again oh oh no no
I changed I would have changed more a
lot more for you for us
I
love you but you won't
or can't oh oh maybe someday but not
today it is not this day
goodbye Bruce
okay
Bruce the bad guy how could you Coy I
mean bat in the cat gotta break your
heart
I should have known let's just rewind 20
minutes and then they were so happy I
love the the moral quandary of like yeah
Catwoman killed the guy Batman's still
wrong like it's like that that's such a
beautiful summation of so many moving
Parts oh yeah absolutely
foreign
the Batman the Batman
the hush Batman hush well koibert what
did you think how did this stack up so
uh I love the Batman hush comic and I
remember it differently okay but I read
it
it was actually wow I just realized I
love Jim Lee's Art so much Batman hush
was when I first started subscribing
monthly to DC books oh wow so like I was
reading DC but I wasn't like uh uh like
collect stack of so I I remember I
bought uh Batman hush and Superman
oh I think it's called like of tomorrow
and it's basically Jim Lee on Superman
and I remember that's what got me to
like start physically collecting DC was
this and and Superman Jim Lee wow uh but
that's when I was reading it so 15 years
ago sure uh maybe 20. good
um so I am maybe misremembering and
maybe this is a spoiler but
um oh okay uh I thought that hush wasn't
Riddler I thought hush was Thomas
Elliott that's what I thought okay I
thought that that's what they were
trying to do yeah I think he is in the
comic book and I was very confused when
it was Riddler okay because all right I
remember very distinctly Thomas Elliott
being hush
sure okay and now I'm thinking it'd be
kind of cool if the Batman has hush come
in the third movie and they we all think
it's Thomas Elliot then it's Paul
Daniels back oh my God
like they have the hush money they have
all the like terminology they have the
the someone from his Pad like they could
make hush
so this was fun because I kept being
like Greg warned me it was different and
I also remember the hush comic being
more of like a
um Batman goes through the
um
kind of like goes through his rogue's
Gallery trying to figure out who she is
it feels much more like I've got to
fight the villain of the week but
they're all his big villains so it was
this really cool Pace where it was like
him beating up and taking apart his
villains to solve this mystery so this
didn't quite feel like that but it had
them all it was just very different tone
I don't remember there being much bat
family and I definitely don't remember
the Superman element being that major of
it but yeah what'd you think yeah I mean
this was fun it was yeah it's it's it
was that like summed up in like that
quick Montage where it's like oh they
took out Penguins I feel like he has to
freeze and then they and it's just three
panels or whatever whereas in the comics
like each each issue felt like a
different villain but there were some
moments that actually didn't quite
translate to animation for me like the
um like the Joker with the bang gun is
like the the last still of a comic book
and they like paused on it for a sec and
like they did the thing they did I think
a little better in Dark Knight Returns
where they would like there's an iconic
image
um it's just like Jim Lee's Art is so
specific I feel like it just doesn't
quite land in motion here sure that
makes sense I I get where you're coming
from I was nice to see because it made
me go like oh that's how the book ended
like I still got it still sparked Joy
condo would say her ex joy so you will
not be discarding I will not be
discarded uh this was like a solid four
star out of five for me this was like
you know in the upper half
um but it wasn't it wasn't uh you know
it's not top five but it's up there okay
yeah that makes sense what'd you think I
liked it yeah I mean I I would be very
curious to go back and finish reading
the the book because now now I'm just
sitting here going tonight did I finish
reading this book and because they're
also there are other stories that have
twists where somebody close to Batman
who doesn't seem like a regular villain
becomes I think I'm like mask the
Phantasm kind of has that right yeah or
like you know it's you're thinking like
oh who is this new villain and who maybe
among the Rogues could be involved but
then in somebody else that's right maybe
I'm just thinking about that but the
fact that we're both misremembering it
is interesting because I really think it
was him well because I guess the thing
was when I was watching this I kept
feeling like that was what they were
trying to set up like that was like uh
and it was much more about like him
being bad to the people close to him
which made it Thomas like the hush you
know from his past and all that stuff
it's yeah there's like resentment right
yeah yeah because that's what I remember
these names are funny you paused on Tara
Strong is not uh Harley here she's
reporter and commissioner Gordon's
played by a guy with all the Wayne's
names Bruce Thomas Bruce Thomas there
you go and uh hey everyone Peyton List
was Batgirl and Poison Ivy yeah
yeah
that's crazy she's uh Tori yeah yeah
yeah that's cool
um no I enjoyed this quite a bit I mean
I like The Vibes uh and and now I'm
really curious to go back and look at
the comic because so much of what I
liked about this was like the bad family
stuff and the Batman and cats like is
the bat in the cat stuff is prominent
that's that's in there because like the
way Jim Lee and and the way Jim Lee's
composition works it's so like romantic
between the two of them and then I do
remember like years later obviously
they're now together or now they're not
again but for years they were together
and I remember this being like a big
like oh my God Batman Revealed yeah no I
love that stuff and like you know we've
been sitting here talking about romance
and passion in these yeah all kinds of
movies and uh and you know we had we had
like stuff like that in the death of
Superman certainly with Lois Lane
um but yeah to come here and to really
have like a full-on you know love story
of Blossom between them and see the ways
they've changed and yeah see the
interplay between Selena and Bruce and
Cat uh Catwoman and Batman and uh the
merging of the two ideas for both of
these people like I really enjoyed and
and kind of got attached to that stuff
so by the end you know when she's yeah
going her separate way like it was such
a tragic end it to you know just like
the most Batman yeah conundrum ever yeah
which someone died that's his code yeah
and like you know certainly he would
have every reason to want to kill
Riddler in this moment and especially he
like freaking dug up
Thomas Elliott like oh yeah I think so
yeah it's like it's real messed up but
uh yeah like overall I would say yeah
it's not like my top favorite but I
definitely enjoyed the ride and I think
it definitely gave me something in that
romance that I really have been you know
just like looking forward to it's such a
big party so many stories yeah we keep
talking about it and I feel like the DC
animateds do romance better than any of
the superhero live action we get lately
certainly except Deadpool of course well
because because yeah because I feel like
a lot of the time there isn't as much
investment just it's just not as the the
live-action romances don't feel as
invested in really spending time on
romance which yeah granted is not what
everybody wants but uh I don't know I
always enjoy partly because
yeah and we're at a point now where I'm
used to like again we're we're post like
uh everything doesn't need to have a
love story and now we've really done
that for a long time where it's like
yeah there's not really much love going
on and so now I'm like bring it back
like I'd like Joy back bring back joy
and love but yeah I like to I liked
having poison ivy be prominent in here I
like Bane and stuff like that um but you
know poison ivy not like Belle
yeah now it's okay who's yeah who is
this painless yeah I just read it off
too I should listen more no my brain
forgot in the moment that I was not just
thinking Karate Kid yeah you know and we
got Lady Shiva for like two seconds yep
which I wonder if that'll come back in a
I imagine that continues on because
there's what three more in this DC
something like that or whatever yeah
like that uh yeah I definitely enjoyed
it the voice provinces were great
scarecrow was really cool looking just
like yeah scarecrow a lot the Moonlight
was cool uh Joker I enjoyed the
different take of
um it was you know a lot of like
highlight reel stuff like Joker having
love towards Batman and like the
jealousy and yeah getting to see like we
got the greatest hits villains which is
what I remembered from hush
in a different way and I enjoyed it okay
yeah yeah well and I do appreciate that
whole bit with the joker of like you
know if Batman's beating him senseless
and he's like I I would normally I would
be all about this but I want it to be
something I am actually responsible for
and if there's one character yeah I
absolutely believe that from it is Joker
100 and that's another thing that did
really well was like each of the
characters though with brief time did
feel like an issue of comic book where
they got their time to shine yeah this
still felt you know pretty substantial
and there still felt like there was a
lot going on and it felt like a movie
like there were moments where I was like
oh they're like giving it time to
breathe here they're going over here
even though it's an hour and 20 minutes
that was definitely like build up of
character relationships yeah yeah
absolutely this this is one of those
ones that leaves me with a unique
feeling because I'm sitting here going
like I like this a lot there's a lot I
even loved about this it does feel like
spiritually there's like something off
that hasn't yeah like 100 clicked into
place or isn't like a full-on
representation so yeah now I'm sitting
here going like did I read more
yeah because if you know that much like
that's definitely a pretty pretty deep
into a book because yeah again I don't
know if it was just you know them doing
a good job misleading me here being like
I don't know man something better the
whole thing once and you're like there's
a splinter in my mind yes yeah yeah I
feel like this right now the whole
audience is like and I mean the twist
with the Riddler I think is an
interesting take because yeah it's like
you're has anybody that must have
happened in other ways in other comics
where they like take a classic character
of some kind and then recontext yeah and
like Riddler's leveled up since and I
think he was c-list then I just don't
remember that now I I kind of glad I
didn't reread house right before this
because this gets to be like a Crux and
I want to reread hush I actually have
like an Elsa I have hush art on my wall
like I love hush but I wanted to reread
it because the fact that I don't
remember the ending well enough to be
definitive about it is it's been 20
years or whatever yeah which is crazy
like yeah I think I think they did a
good job adapting it and if they changed
it great if they didn't change it great
but I think they did a good job like
making the mystery work and there is
something that feels just a little off
but overall like I really enjoyed it um
love the continuation of the the rain
Wilson Lex Luthor just like even for
that line and it makes me really excited
to see whatever we have next in this
world that's approaching its end because
yeah this is 2019. yeah yeah we're
catching up to the present we need more
double dates yeah dude you gotta read
that it's it's Tom King uh who I talk
about a lot and it's two issues and it
is just so charming and delightful and
wonderful it's the two of them and I
love it dearly oh it's called double
date it's so good well then I will be
picking that up the second we cut the
camera yeah get them Comics uh little
mini Coy's comic Corners right as plug
Comics during the mid uh animated
episode but yeah I feel like there's not
as much to say on this one yeah anyway
it's like it's just straightforward it
is what it is yeah
and you're like this is an iconic run
and so yeah you expect this to be like a
big punctuation movie where really it it
more like you know looking at this DC
AMU Journey it feels like yes certain
installments you know they're all movies
they all stand on their own but some
feel like you know culminative
punctuated events and others feel like
okay we're back in the you know sort of
main we're just kind of back in the
episodics of the timeline right or
something like that so like and maybe it
was the speed of going through everyone
but like having a greatest hits villain
movie be an hour and 20 though it worked
as a movie maybe that's why it feels
like well that's what it was like it
just doesn't have yeah can't really go
further than that yeah because you know
it's the most substantial stuff is the
Bruce and Selena batting the cat stuff
yeah you get a little bit Gordon you get
a little bit of your other you know you
get some Nightwing and some Alfred and
then yeah the rest of the villains stuff
is mostly like you know they get their
moment Bane Joker Harley yeah and then
uh yeah you get a couple other little
clay clay face but yeah it's like it's
yeah it's not as jam-packed with stuff
yeah and because there's so much it
can't go deeper than that really yeah uh
well that I believe is gonna do it for
Batman hush which I enjoyed uh in my top
third not my top five uh very excited I
think this is our 21st one of these I
think we just hit 21 DC animateds we
have watched so I think we're
approaching halfway of all of them and I
know we're approaching the end of this
shared universe that's exciting so we're
going to keep cruising along leave a
comment let us know which one you're
excited to see us watch next let us know
which uh of these you've enjoyed the
most and also if you were angry that we
didn't remember who hush was I'm excited
to join you in knowing by reading the
comic again because I love this comic so
it's gonna be a ton of comments like
it's obviously but uh very excited to
dive back in uh thank you for watching
as always thank you to our patrons for
being patrons and share this so we can
keep making these I want to keep
watching I want to finish off the 40 or
whatever there are so we got to make
sure people get to click and sew
notification Bell like comment All That
Jazz reject Nation you're lovely we'll
see you soon and before we get out of
here let us give a very special shout
out to patreon
I gotta go back into the archives from
last month but if we happen to miss you
I am sorry I take personal
responsibility in you so you are one of
our longest running you're one of our
best friends you are the Thomas uh
what's his name I keep wanting to call
him Thomas Edison but that's Thomas
you're the lady Thomas Elliott of this
channel you were a remarkable person you
stand by us you're steadfast even though
we're always out here you know just like
batting around and and you know we never
got time to just pal around but you know
what we have paddled around once or
twice and I'm glad that you're still
alive and we can do so again one day all
you can come next time yeah me and Greg
have gone to hang out with Denise she's
a class act so next time you can join we
can have a whole big project family
party yeah the the pizza places were
open for the pandemic and I had that big
like thing we all got pizza yeah that
was great I miss pizza parties dude
quirky Mark pizza party pizza party
you're invited you're an honorary
invited love you Nisa stay well and uh
and hey you might get two shout outs
this month just to make up for it so uh
you know you feel feel blessed with the
outpouring of Love June extra love
access absolutely I do too stay pledge
we're gonna get some pizza yeah we're
gonna get some pizza
[Music]